Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Et si on remettait les climatologues
à leur place ?
J’ai conscience qu’en disant ça,
je suis un peu taquin.
Je vais vous expliquer.
Il y a un rapport, qui est en train
de paraître, en trois parties,
la première partie est parue
en août dernier, la deuxième en février.
Le troisième arrive.
C’est le sixième rapport
de l’évaluation du GIEC.
On en parle beaucoup,
mais seulement dans certains cercles.
On en parle très peu dans les médias.
Ce rapport, il est remarquable.
Maintenant, concrètement, effectivement,
selon moi, il y a un souci.
Il y a un souci,
pas dans ce que font les climatologues,
mais peut-être dans ce qu’ils ne font pas.
Il y a un souci dans la manière
dont la problématique climatique
est prise en compte dans le débat.
Donc j’ai deux messages aujourd’hui.
Le premier, c’est que je pense
que la problématique est mal posée.
Est-ce que l’humanité est face à
un grave problème de climat ?
Oui, mais est-ce que c’est
LE grave problème ?
Moi, je pense pas.
Je vais vous expliquer ce qu’est,
selon moi, le grave problème.
Le grave problème,
c’est que notre civilisation
est une machine thermodynamique
qui transforme l’environnement
dans lequel on vit
en prélevant des ressources.
Ensuite, on transforme ces ressources,
on les utilise : des biens,
des services, les activités
humaines, les sociétés humaines.
Et puis, en aval, on recrache
des déchets et des pollutions.
On reboucle certaines petites choses
dans ce système.
on circularise certaines
sous-parties du système.
Mais globalement, c’est un flux linéaire
qui transforme la nature en déchets.
Les déchets sont solides,
liquides ou gazeux.
Parmi les gaz, une sous-partie,
les gaz à effet de serre,
dérèglent le climat.
Le changement climatique
est une des multiples sous-parties
avec des multiples conséquences
de ce problème qui fait que,
en amont, on prélève plus de ressources
que ce que la Terre
peut durablement donner,
pour ce qui est renouvelable,
au-delà du taux de renouvellement.
En aval, on génère plus de pollution
que ce que le système peut durablement
absorber, pour ce qui peut l’être,
Et au passage, on transforme, on détruit,
la capacité d’adaptation de nature.
On détruit plus vite que la capacité
de régénération de la nature.
Ce flux est trop grand.
Le système Terre ne peut plus s’adapter.
Et voilà, selon moi,
la nature de la problématique.
Le climat est un grave problème
parmi d’autres graves problèmes.
On attaque la problématique du climat
comme LE grand problème aujourd’hui,
pour ceux qui s’en préoccupent,
ça nous est présenté
comme LE super méga défi à relever.
C'est un défi, je ne le nie pas.
Mais le problème,
c’est qu’on confond deux choses :
on confond les maux et les symptômes.
On traite du climat comme un mal
alors qu’il n’est qu’un symptôme.
Je vais vous expliquer avec une métaphore,
qui a le mérite d’être claire,
pourquoi c’est grave comme méprise.
Imaginez que vous ayez
des maux de crâne chroniques,
des problèmes de peau et en plus de ça,
un problème de transit.
Si vous traitez ces choses différemment,
comme des problèmes,
vous allez pouvoir trouver des solutions :
pour le crâne, du paracétamol,
pour la peau, de la pommade,
pour le transite, de la tisane.
Toutes ces choses-là sont
des petits aménagements.
On peut continuer à vivre normalement,
on soulage les symptômes
avec un peu de paracétamol,
de pommade
et on continue à vivre normalement
Maintenant, imaginez que l’ensemble
de ces choses-là, de ces symptômes,
sont en fait les conséquences du fait
que vous avez un cancer généralisé.
(je vous avais dit que ce serait drôle…)
Imaginez. Vous croyez
qu’en mangeant du paracétamol,
en mettant de la pommade,
vous allez guérir le cancer ?
Non, il faut bien comprendre
que traiter la cause
n’est absolument pas la même chose
que la somme des traitements
des symptômes.
C’est fondamentalement différent.
Parce que ce n’est que
quand on a compris le cancer
qu’on comprend la nécessité
d’un traitement choc,
qu’on comprend que la survie est en jeu
et que pour survivre,
il faut faire d’énormes sacrifices.
Une chimiothérapie par exemple,
ce sont d’énormes sacrifices.
C’est toute la vie qui change, qui se
réorganise autour de ça.
C’est beaucoup de souffrances
pour survivre
parce qu’on comprend
que c’est la survie qui est en jeu,
Et là, on fait tout ce qu’il faut.
Si nous étions logiques
en tant qu’humanité,
ce qu’on ferait aujourd’hui,
c’est un traitement de choc.
On arrêterait tout ce qu’on fait,
on se réorganiserait
entièrement pour survivre.
Qu’est-ce qui est en jeu aujourd’hui ?
C’est notre survie ?
La vôtre ? La mienne ?
Non, c’est bien plus que ça :
ce qui est en jeu aujourd’hui
et ce qui se joue
dans les trente prochaines années,
c'est l'habitabilité de la planète Terre,
pour l'essentiel du vivant.
Voilà ce qui est en train de se jouer.
Et face à ça, on prend du paracétamol.
Lorsque l’on traite le climat,
lorsqu’on essaie de, par exemple,
décarboner la civilisation, c’est bien.
Faisons-le !
On soulage le symptôme
“changement climatique”
qui est tellement grave qu’à lui seul
il peut nous tuer, donc faisons-le.
Et pourtant, si on ne fait que ça,
le cancer est toujours là !
Si on traite séparément les différents
problèmes, par exemple le climat,
mais par exemple aussi
la biodiversité qui s’effondre
et la nature qui est totalement détruite,
par exemple aussi
les pollutions qui s’accumulent,
l’accès à certaines ressources,
l’accès à l’eau,
le dérèglement des cycles biogéochimiques,
les cycles de nutriments
comme le phosphore.
Ce sont tout un tas de problèmes
qui sont tous extrêmement graves,
qui sont en réalité interdépendants.
Et essayer de les traiter indépendamment
les uns des autres n'a aucun sens.
Ce que l’on fait, c’est soulager
certains symptômes et en général,
on fait ça sans cohérence systémique.
on aggrave d’autres symptômes.
Par exemple, la stratégie qui voudrait
que l’on développe les renouvelables
pour gérer le problème climatique,
ça donne quoi ?
Dans nos sociétés à nous,
les sociétés riches
(c’est surtout nous
que ça concerne en fait),
on va développer les nouvelles
technologies et ces technologies,
elles calment un peu le jeu au niveau
du climat, c’est très bien,
mais par ailleurs,
elles accentuent les flux extractifs :
on extrait plus de ressources en amont
(des métaux, des minerais…)
pour cette histoire-là… et au passage
on détruit l’environnement,
on fait chuter encore plus
la biodiversité, on pollue,
on utilise un maximum d’eau,
il y a des problèmes de santé,
d’hygiène, des problèmes sociaux, etc.
On va aggraver certains symptômes
pour en soigner un.
Je ne dis pas qu’il ne faut pas le faire,
je dis juste, n’imaginons pas
que ça va résoudre le problème.
Ça va déplacer le problème,
ça va transformer le problèm
en d’autres symptômes.
Voilà aujourd’hui ce qu’on fait.
on soulage certains symptômes
et à côté de ça,
ce qu’il se passe,
c’est qu’on en aggrave d’autres.
Il n'y a pas de cohérence systémique.
Parlons de transition énergétique.
si on arrivait à mettre
de l’énergie décarbonée
au service de notre société
mais sans changer de projet de société,
simplement on mettrait de l’énergie,
décarbonée, ce serait mieux,
au service d’un flux qui transforme
la nature en déchets.
Voilà ce qui se passerait,
ça ne changerait pas grand-chose.
Vous comprenez le problème ?
Aujourd’hui, nous avons,
face à nous, de grands enjeux,
mais le problème fondamental n’est pas
un problème de climat,
mais de dépassement des limites
du système Terre.
Et c'est de ça qu'on devrait parler.
Si on n’en parle pas, on risque
de se retrouver dans un cas
qui est ce qu’on appelle la maladaptation.
Même le GIEC dit « attention aux
phénomènes de maladaptation ! »
Le problème, c’est que si on suit
uniquement et en silo
les recommendations du GIEC,
certes on va évite
la maladaptation vis à vis du climat,
mais on sera dans une autre forme
de la maladaptation,
celle
vis à vis du système Terre.
Il faut dézoomer un petit peu.
Alors si on s’attaquait à la cause,
vraiment, on ferait quoi ?
On organiserait une descent
énergétique et matérielle.
On diminuerait les flux d’énergie,
les flux de matières,
on ferait tout ce qu’il faut
pour régénérer la nature.
Pour ça, il faudrait qu’on change
notre rapport à la nature.
C’est un grand changement,
à la fois dans ce que l’on produit,
comment on consomme,
et ce que l’on consomme,
et comment on se comporte vis-à-vis
les uns des autres, et de la nature.
C’est un grand changement culturel,
anthropologique,
et ça, il faut qu’on le fasse au niveau
mondial dans les 10  années qui viennent.
Vous y croyez ?
C’est compliqué,
c’est pas sûr qu’on y arrive.
Aujourd’hui le problème,
si on s’attaquait à ça,
c’est qu’il faudrait tout changer,
et les gens ne le veulent pas.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que cette grande descente
énergétique et matérielle,
diminuer les flux d’énergie
de matières, est vitale.
Mais qu’est-ce qu’elle implique
sur nos sociétés ?
Elle implique qu'on doit diminuer
la taille des économies.
Il y a des gens qui vont
soutenir le contraire, qui diront :
« On peut découpler,
faire de la croissance verte,
continuer à croître économiquement
mais on va soulager la nature. »
C’est faux.
Celui qui affirme ça.
je pense qu’il va ne vous parler
que des gaz à effet de serre,
et il va prendre certains exemples :
« Tel pays a réussi à découpler,
il y a moins de gaz à effet de serre
alors que le taux de croissance
économique est toujours positif. »
C’est pas parce qu’un pays
a pu le faire que le monde peut le faire.
Certains pays riches désindustrialisés
peuvent le faire
parce que d’autres pays produisent
massivement ce que nous on ne produit pas.
Ce n’est pas extrapolable
à l’ensemble de la planète.
Là on ne parle que des gaz
à effet de serre, vous avez compris,
que ce n’est
qu’une dimension de l’affaire,
pour tout le reste,
il n’y a pas de découplage.
Plus d’économie,
c’est moins de pollution ?
Non, toujours plus, on n’est pas
en découplage, mais en surcouplage.
Plus d’économie, moins de destruction
environnementale ? Non, surcouplage.
Plus d’économie,
c’est moins de ressources ? Non ! Plus !
On intensifie les flux de ressources
comme jamais auparavant.
Pour produire un point de PIB aujourd’hui,
on utilise plus de matières premières
qu’il y a vingt ans.
On ne se rapproche pas d’un découplage,
on s’en éloigne.
Donc la croissance verte ? Pas possible.
Il faut diminuer les flux
d’énergie et de matières,
cette descente énergétique et matérielle
doit s’organiser, de toute façon
si on ne le fait pas, on va la subir.
C’est une chaîne de Ponzi,
notre économie mondiale,
il faut rajouter toujours plus d’énergie
et de matières, sinon ça s’effondre.
Mauvaise nouvelle : on va en avoir
de moins en moins à partir de maintenant.
Alors, on le comprend et on l’organise ?
Ou on se met en position juste de subir ?
Donc le problème,
c’est que pour l’instant,
on évite de remettre en question
quoi que ce soit.
Il faudrait réécrire tout le logiciel
économique, social, politique, etc.,
on ne veut pas le faire, c’est trop !
On a l’idée que
si on ne croît pas économiquement,
c’est la fin du progrès.
Effectivement, jusqu’ici, il y a eu
des progrès dus à la croissance.
Mais le fait est que ce n’était
pas vraiment dû à la croissance,
c’est dû au fait qu’on investissait
dans les infrastructures, la santé,
l’éducation, des choses qui ont
effectivement amélioré la vie des gens.
Aujourd’hui, la croissance,
c’est qu’au lieu de deux,
vous avez huit écrans chez vous.,
vous êtes plus heureux ?
Dans d’autres pays,
des gens ont besoin de croître.
Si et seulement si on investit
dans ces choses essentielles,
Pour le reste, plus besoin de croître.
C’est mon premier message aujourd’hui :
le climat n’est qu’un problème
parmi d’autres et pour le résoudre,
il faut remonter à la cause des causes.
Ça veut dire réduire
les flux d’énergie et de matières,
cela signifie réduire
la taille de notre économie.
Celui qui vous soutient, une fois de plus,
le contraire est un idéologue.
Moi je ne suis pas un idéologue,
je suis un ingénieur.
Et pour pouvoir le faire sans que ce soi
une casse sociale, une casse humaine,
il faut des projets
pour réorganiser une société,
et ce sont des changements majeurs.
Ça, c’est mon premier message,
Le deuxième message, c’est que
ça va être compliqué,
d’arriver à faire tout ça.
Et d’arriver à faire ça au niveau mondial.
Et dans les prochaines années.
Donc il manque quelque chose.
Il manque quelque chose d’essentiel
dans toutes les stratégies déployées,
y compris celle du GIEC.
Aujourd’hui, c’est quoi,
la démarche du GIEC ?
Y’a pas que le GIEC, c’est général !
Le GIEC est organisé
en trois groupes de travail :
le groupe de travail qui étudie
la science du changement climatique
l’adaptation au changement climatique,
et enfin le troisième, sur l’atténuation
du changement climatique.
La stratégie c’est :
on atténue et on s’adapte ;
on va adapter nos sociétés au changement.
La question que je pose, c’est :
et si on n’y arrivait pas,
c’est quoi le plan B ?
Ça, c’est le plan A,
On mise tout là-dessus, sur la capacité
à adapter nos sociétés ?
Et si on n’y arrivait pas,
pas assez bien, pas assez profondément,
pas assez vite ?
Et si on arrivait à des pannes,
à des moments où ça bascule,
où ce qui est essentiel pour la survie
de tout le monde arrête de fonctionner ?
Pas du jour au lendemain,
pas pour tout le monde, sans doute,
mais de grands pans qui tomberaient
en panne, qu’est-ce qu’on fait ?
C’est quoi le plan B ?
Ils sont où, les canots de sauvetage ?
Ce que je vous dis, c’est qu’il faut
un groupe de travail numéro 4 au GIEC,
qui travaille dessus.
Et si ça ne suffisait pas,
ce que proposent
les groupes de travail 2 et 3 ?
Donc un plan B.
Et ce plan B, c’est une nouvelle
façon de vivre,
une nouvelle façon de faire les choses.
C’est pas juste comment on produit
et on consomme.
Souvent, on vous dit
ce que vous pouvez faire ou pas,
arrêter de prendre l’avion,
ou en tout cas moins,
moins de viande, etc…
Tout ce qu’on vous dit que vous pouvez
faire, c’est en tant que consommateurs !
Allez-y, faites-le,
ça joue dans l’équation,
il faut faire beaucoup d’efforts, tous.
Mais qu’est-ce que vous pouvez faire
en tant que citoyens, collectivement ?
Pour moi, c’est là que ça se joue.
Collectivement… pour peser.
D’un côté peser, comme je l’ai dit,
sur le système en place,
essayer de le faire évoluer, l’amender,
de l’aménager de
toutes les manières possibles,
réécrire les règles, mais aussi,
à côté, des canots de sauvetage
au cas où on n’y arriverait pas
dans le temps imparti,
on n’a plus beaucoup de temps,
les choses s’accélèrent.
Des exponentielles s’installent
un peu partout.
Alors c’est quoi qu’on fait à côté,
les canots de sauvetage ?
La résilience est au cœur de ce système.
Mais la résilience collective,
On nous dit, des fois : « Les humains
sont capables de résilience. »
Oui, individuellement.
Mais la somme
des résiliences individuelles
ne fait pas une résilience collective.
Si les résiliences individuelles
ont un penchant individualiste,
on voit bien tout de suite
que ça ne va pas tendre
à une résilience d’ensemble, sociétale.
Comment met-on en place une résilience,
et quel type de résilience ?
C’est pas celle du GIEC !
Parce que le GIEC aussi vous parle
de résilience, mais laquelle ?
La résilience climatique,
face à des aléas climatiques.
Je vous parle d’autre chose.
Je vous dis que le problème
n’est pas que climatique,
c’est le dépassement des limites
du système Terre.
Derrière, ça va détériorer
de manière durable,
irréversible parfois, nos sociétés.
Donc qu’est-ce qu’on fait
quand nos sociétés se délitent ?
Que fait-on quand ce qu’on a prévu
pour gérer les crises ponctuelles
ne suffit pas ?
Qu’est ce qu’on fait
quand il ya des pénuries définitives,
quand il y a une descente énergétique
et matérielle imposée, non prévue
donc subie plus ou moins
dans le chaos, et irréversible ?
Que fait-on ? C’est là
qu’on a besoin d’une résilience
qui n’est pas juste la capacité
à rebondir après un choc
et à revenir à une « normale »,
mais qui est commen
on se transforme collectivement
pour être capables de s’auto-organiser
dans la durée, dans le temps,
d’une manière collective,
si possible solidaire et digne,
fraternelle, et également en fraternité
avec le reste de la nature.
On en est loin, mais justement,
il faut le créer !
Ça, ça s’appelle la résilience collective,
sociétale, au sens large
et c’est celle-là dont on a besoin.
Voilà , c'est mon deuxième message.
Non seulement le climat
n’est qu’un sous-problème
d’un problème largement plus grave
dont on ne parle toujours pas,
mais en plus de ça il faut créer
des canots de sauvetage,
un plan B au cas où le plan A
ne fonctionnerait pas.
Nous avons globalement deux grands
challenges qui s’imposent à nous.
Aujourd’hui on est en amont
d’une présidentielle :
le débat dans le cadre de cette
présidentielle est catastrophique.
Catastrophique ! On élude tous les grands
problèmes de ce monde, tous.
Ils sont à peine évoqués
par certains des candidats.
C’est de la faute des candidats,
mais aussi beaucoup des journalistes
qui ne posent pas les bonnes questions
et sont à côté de la plaque.
Début février, 1400 chercheurs
ont exhorté, dans une tribune,
les candidats et les médias
à enfin parler du climat.
Donc oui, ok, bien sûr
parlons du climat !
Mais vous voyez ?
Ça ne va pas plus loin que ça.
On dit aujourd’hui,
et c’est une bonne nouvelle,
que le climat,
c’est un problème « systémique ».
Le fait qu’il est important de voir
les choses d’une manière systémique,
ça commence un peu à s’installer.
Le dernier rapport du GIEC
est très clair là-dessus,
le climat est un problème systémique.
Et ça suffit, ça ? Non.
Cette systémique-là doit s’intégrer,
doit être réintégrée,
dans une systémique
encore beaucoup plus large,
qui est la systémique du système Terre
dans son intégralité.
Ce n’est toujours pas le cas !
Aujourd’hui, ça, on ne le fait pas !
Donc il faut recadrer considérablement ça,
parce qu’aujourd’hui,
dans le meilleur des cas,
on appelle à considérer
le climat, c’est bien mais…
Ceux qui se mobilisent le font
sur la cerise et personne sur le gâteau.
On a plusieurs trains
conceptuels de retard
sur la caractérisation de la problématique
et donc sur celle de l’espace
des réponses possibles.
Et mon dernier message concerne
le fait qu’on manque d’une stratégie
pour organiser cette descente
énergétique et matérielle
qui sera donc, de toute façon,
soit comprise, anticipée, organisée
et potentiellement au moins
en partie pilotée,
ou qui sera subie dans le chaos.
Personnellement,
je préfère la première option.
L’enjeu c’est l’habitabilité
de la planète Terre,
et ça se passe maintenant.
Donc le choix nous appartient.
Il est entre les mains
de toutes les citoyennes
et de tous les citoyens
qui sommeillent en nous tous.
Réveillons-les !